thank you very much today we continue to
send our love to the great people of New
York and New Jersey we support them
fully we grieve alongside every family
who has lost a precious loved one
New Yorkers are tough and strong and
brave New Jersey i'ts are tough and
strong and brave and they're being hit
very hard right now and for the next
week hopefully not much longer than that
it's gonna start to go in the other
direction our country is being hit hard
but some areas have done so incredibly
well we're so proud of them they will
beat this virus we're gonna beat it with
the grit and the heart for which they're
known and for which our country is known
and we appreciate everything that
everybody is doing willing we also we
pray for Prime Minister Boris Johnson
has become a great friend of ours he
loves this country he loves his country
but he loves the USA and he's always
been very good to us whenever we had
difficulty he was with us and we
appreciate it so we pray for Prime
Minister Boris Johnson it's going
through a lot as we intensify our
military campaign against the virus I
think that it must be brought out that
we have to thank the American people for
continuing to follow our guidelines on
slowing the spread an expression that
more and more people are thinking about
nobody ever heard of it two months ago
and now everybody is talking about
slowing the spread stopping this spread
even during this painful week we see
glimmers of very very strong hope and
this will be a very painful week and
next week at least part of next week but
probably all of it look if one person
dies it's a painful week and we know
that's going to unfortunately happen
this is a monster we're fighting
but signs are that our strategy is
totally working every American has a
role to play in winning this war and
we're going to be winning it we're gonna
be winning it powerfully and we'll be
prepared for the next one should it
happen but hopefully it won't our
massive airlift operation for critical
supplies it's called Project airbridge
continued today as five massive planes
flights landed in the United States
packed with personal protective
equipment and our nation's heroic health
care workers will be the beneficiaries
of that 27 more flights are scheduled in
the near future over the next couple of
weeks the Army Corps of Engineers is
constructing facilities that will
support more than 15,000 hospital beds
to treat patients in need so they're
building now approximately 15,000 they
just completed the big one in New York
they've just completed enter in the
process of continuing in Chicago and
many other places they're incredible the
Army Corps of Engineers we owe them a
lot what they were able to do in such a
short period of time they'll build these
massive facilities 2,000 beds in four
days so it's really something very
special I know I was in the construction
industry and you don't see that happen
very often I want to remind governor's
and emergency managers that sharing real
time data with us about equipment and
their needs is very important all of
their supplies hospital occupancy is
critical a lot of the occupancy is
really getting a little bit lower than
anticipated and that's good we sort of
thought that was going to happen and
we're getting along very well with the
governor's this whole situation with
respect to talking to us about equipment
and equipment knees giving us a little
bit of lead time so important all the
supplies we're getting it to everybody
like they never thought possible but
we'll ensure that we can rapidly deploy
federal assets
where and when they're needed especially
on ventilators we're actually getting
some mental eaters back as you know the
state of California was great they sent
some back which they won't need and
Washington State likewise and we have
some others coming back so we're using
them in areas we need them we are
pressing forward aggressively on the
scientific frontier of the medical war
the companies I've spoke to the four
leading I comb the genius companies
they're doing incredibly well with
respect to cures and also with respect
to a vaccine that's going to protect us
totally protect us and they have some
great potential it's going to take a
little while yet but they have some
great potential some great early results
and the governor has been working hard
and we are working hard with the
governor's has been great coordination
especially over the last little while we
give them a lot of equipment a lot of
ventilators but a lot of equipment of
all types and I will protect you of your
governor fails if you have a governor
that's failing we're going to protect
you but the governors are working well
with us over the last period of time
today in our stockpile of ventilators
and again we need the stockpile so we
can immediately move them from place to
place wherever the monster hits it's a
monster we have eight thousand six
hundred and seventy five ventilators
right now in stock ready to move and we
have all sorts of incredible soldiers
our military is going to move them
should they be needed in as an example
if we need additional in New York or or
the New York City area if state you have
city and spoke to mayor de Blasio and we
really have a great well coordinated
campaign with mayor de Blasio it's been
really good spoke to Governor Cuomo has
been great coordination so if they need
something we have it if Louisiana needs
something we have it
same thing with Michigan's same thing
with Illinois they're certains
that are very hot and we'll see what
happens but we'll know pretty much who
have time and we'll be able to move it
in addition to the eight thousand six
hundred and seventy five ventilators we
have two thousand two hundred arriving
on April 13th we have five thousand five
hundred arriving on May fourth these are
ones that we're building for the most
part and we have as you know great
companies building them for General
Motors GE we have really some great
companies that are doing it on may 18th
we have 12,000 on June 1st we have
20,000 on June 29th we have 60,000
ventilators coming 66 oh so we have a
total of a hundred and ten thousand
ventilators coming over a short period
of time I don't think we'll need them
hopefully we won't need them I don't
think we'll need anywhere near them
we'll have them for the future and we'll
also be able to help other countries who
are desperate for ventilators the UK
called today and they wanted to know
would it be possible to get 200 and
we're going to work it out we got to
work it out they've been great partners
United Kingdom and we're gonna work it
out for them so they wanted 200 they
needed them desperately we now have 10
drugs and active trials with 15 more
soon to follow as well as to vaccine
candidates in active clinical trials
we'll do whatever it takes to secure
needed medical supplies and bring more
production of essential medicines back
to our shores we're doing that we're
bringing them back to our shores a lot
of these companies they went a little
bit haywire they went away from this
great country and they had them produced
elsewhere so we're gonna start bringing
it back I've been talking about that for
a long time not only with medical but
lots of other things America continues
to perform more tests than any other
nation in the world and I think that's
probably why we have more cases because
when you look at some of these very
large countries they I know they know
for a fact that they have far more cases
than we do but they don't
report them we've performed 1.87 million
tests today so that's 1 million eight
hundred and seventy thousand million
tests think of that 1 million eight
hundred and seventy thousand tests to
date and now we're performing them at a
level that nobody's ever seen before as
we announced yesterday CVS testing sites
in Georgia and Rhode Island will be
using Abbott Labs rapid five-minute
tests we're down to now five minutes
it's a five-minute test so that people
can get the results back very quickly
and we're actively engaging on the
problem of increased impacts there's a
real problem and it's showing up very
strongly and our data on the African
American community and we're doing
everything in our power to address this
challenge it's a tremendous challenge
it's terrible and provide support to
African American citizens of this
country who are going through a lot but
it's been disproportional they're
getting hit very very hard in fact while
we have Tony here I'd like to maybe have
you come up and address that one and
then I'll continue but if you could
address that it would be great touring
please we have a particularly difficult
problem of an exacerbation of a health
disparity we've known literally forever
that diseases like diabetes hypertension
obesity and asthma are
disproportionately afflicting the
minority populations particularly the
African Americans unfortunately when you
look at the predisposing conditions that
lead to a bad outcome with coronavirus
the things that get people into our
ciues that require intubation and often
lead to death they are just those very
comorbidities that are unfortunately
disproportionately prevalent in the
African American population so we're
very concerned about that it's very sad
it's nothing we can do about it right
now except to try and give them the best
possible care to avoid those
complications
thank you very much and Tony I think
you're gonna have some pretty accurate
numbers over the next few days right but
they are very they're very nasty numbers
terrible numbers in total 1200 Abbot
machines average laboratories have been
fantastic have been shipped now
nationwide up to 500 more are being
produced every week and 50,000 testing
cartridges are being manufactured per
day that means a lot of very fast tests
no nation in the world has developed a
more diverse and robust testing capacity
than the United States we're dealing
with other nations helping them out
because the testing is very tough for
them and our tests are very accurate a
lot of tests are out there and they're
not accurate at all in fact some of the
tests you don't have a clue what's going
on so we're working with other nations
trying to get them help also at a time
when many Americans are experiencing
increased stress anxiety and personal
loss we must also ensure that our
country can meet the mental health needs
of those struggling in this crisis there
are people struggling they're struggling
and some people are getting to know each
other frankly some families are getting
to know each other on a positive note
but there are a lot of people struggling
one Thursday I'll be speaking to leaders
and advocates from the mental health
organizations all across our country and
we are going to be talking about
resources and tools that will make
available to them they need help and
it's a big problem when you take
something where it was the most
successful country in the world still is
the whole world is shut down
think of it we're down to numbers that
are incredible as I said yesterday I
think it's 182 countries right now 182
countries are under attack by the by the
scourge by this virus but as we wage
medical war on the virus
we're also speeding economic relief to
our people it's incredible we just had a
meeting that was
absolutely incredible with the banks I
spoke with leaders in the banking and
finance industry about our efforts to
help American workers and employers as
of today small business has processed
more than 70 billion dollars in
guaranteed loans and will provide
much-needed relief for nearly a quarter
of a million businesses already so we
are going to be providing tremendous
amounts of money to these small
businesses of our country have been
absolutely clobbered and they'll be
keeping open and they'll be paying their
employees and they'll be all set to go
we're gonna have a rocket upward I want
to thank David Solomon CEO of goldman
sachs brian moynihan CEO of Bank of
America gordon smith co-president CEO of
JPMorgan Chase Chao Scharf CEO of Wells
Fargo Michael Corbitt CEO of Citigroup
al Kelly CEO of Visa Michael me bak CEO
of MasterCard noah wilcox CEO chairman
of grand rapids state bank and we had
numerous others also on the call and I
just appreciate them they are well way
ahead of schedule by the way we're way
ahead of schedule the Paycheck
protection program has been incredible
so based on the incredible success of
the program I'm announcing that I'll be
asking Congress to provide an additional
250 billion dollars for the Paycheck
protection which will help keep
Americans employed to facilitate a quick
and full recovery we're doing very well
we're looking very bipartisan a lot of
people want to do it and the the plan is
amazing you know they're processing
hundreds of thousands of loans and this
is the big banks that are doing it the
community banks but the biggest banks
right now in our country are doing it in
there they're doing it for a lot of
reasons one of them is they want to help
people
the w-h-o that's the world health
organization receives vast amounts of
money from the United States and we pay
for a majority or biggest portion of
their money and they actually criticized
and disagreed with my travel ban at the
time I did it and they were wrong
they've been wrong about a lot of things
and then a lot of information early and
they didn't want to do very they seem to
be very China centric and we have to
look into that so we're going to look
into it we pay for we give a majority of
the money that they get and it's much
more than the fifty eight fifty eight
million dollars is a small portion of
what they've gotten over the years
sometimes they get much more than that
sometimes it's for programs that they're
doing and and it's much bigger numbers
and if the programs are good that's
great as far as we're concerned but we
want to look into a World Health
Organization because they really are
they called it wrong they call it wrong
they really they missed the call they
could have called it months earlier they
would have known and they should have
known and they probably didn't know so
we'll be looking into that very
carefully and we're gonna put a hold on
money spent to the w-h-o we're gonna put
a very powerful hold on it and we're
gonna see it's a great thing if it works
but when they call every shot wrong
that's no good we're in the midst of a
great national struggle one that
requires the shared sacrifice of all
Americans in recent weeks it's been
remarkable to see so many companies and
organizations and individuals like the
banks that I just told you about biggest
banks in the world they stepped up to
help small business they're big business
small business the small business will
someday be the big business but the
small business is 50% of our economic
strength people don't realize when you
add them up but they just they just rose
to the occasion everybody's rising to
the occasion it's been incredible to
watch to honor and celebrate the
extraordinary examples of patriotism and
citizenship
we're seeing I'm asking Americans to use
the hashtag America works together when
sharing stories of how we're all working
together get through getting through
this ordeal in a fashion that nobody
would have ever thought possible it's
been incredible and that's why the
numbers are so far much better we want
to keep it that way if you look at the
original projections if we did nothing
it would be disastrous if we we decided
to do something we closed it down I had
no choice it was a good move that was a
good move the early China move was a
good move the early Europe law was a
good move but a lot of good moves but
closing it down was a big statement was
a big important thing but we're looking
to have far fewer deaths than originally
thought and I think we're heading in
that direction but it's too early to
talk about it I don't even want to talk
about it now because we just want to
work and I think that people are doing
an incredible job the doctors the nurses
the firefighters the police all medical
people what they're doing the bravery
that they're displaying is just
incredible every citizen should take
immense pride and the selfless
selflessness and all of the courage and
compassion of our people the workers the
people that are working and construction
workers going into hospitals knowing
nothing about this problem other than
it's dangerous and they go in there to
rebuild sections of hospitals and you
have people in really big trouble right
next door they know nothing about it all
they know is they're going to get it
done they're going to fix that wing so
they can have more people in there it's
incredible but this is a national spirit
that won our independence and settled
the frontier and explored the horizons
of space and that's what we're doing I
mean this is all this is all new
territory it unlocked the miracles of
science and we're doing that when you I
wish you could have heard the calls I
had yesterday with these great companies
that come up with cures to
diseases and the success they've had
over the last 15 years is really amazing
so I just want to thank all of them
they're working very hard they're
working with UK right now in the UK
doctors hopefully helping with their
great prime minister but these people
are really tremendous signs of success
are staring us right in the face I think
we're gonna have something that's gonna
be great in terms of vaccines and in
terms of everything else that they're
doing just helping really helping us
helping the people of our country and
helping ultimately the people of the
world so I want to thank you all for
being here I will take some questions
and then I'm gonna give it over to the
vice president and they're gonna go into
great detail on to what we're doing and
all of the successful supplies and
medical equipment that we're getting all
of the ventilators I've said it but you
can go over it in more detail if you'd
like but we're taken in and building
thousands and thousands of enta lighters
and they're very high quality I said you
got to go for the quality and these are
quality companies doing it so because
there is a big difference between a good
ventilator and a not-so-good ventilator
Tony right we've seen that and big
difference so we're going
top-of-the-line Steve please the acting
Navy secretary submitted his resignation
today motely why did that become
necessary and what role did you have in
this sir well I had no role in it I've
heard I don't know him but I've heard he
was a very good man and it was a the
whole thing was a very unfortunate the
captain should not have written a letter
he didn't have to be Ernest Hemingway he
made a mistake but he had a bad day and
I hate seeing bad things happen man made
a mistake but you know he shouldn't be
writing letters and you're in the
military you're the captain of a great
ship and you shouldn't be writing
letters and sending him too many people
and then it gets out to the media and
you know the question is how did he get
out to the media so there's a lot of bad
things happen there and I had heard he
did because he didn't want to cause any
disturbance for our country so that was
a because he wouldn't have had to resign
I would not have asked him I don't know
him I didn't speak to him but he did
that I think just to end in that problem
and I think in one in really many ways
that was a very unselfish thing for him
to do what should happen now the
commander Crozier who that I think the
Secretary of Defense as you know is what
you know marques Burr and he's very
capable and I think he's looking at that
right now they're they're going to just
take it under regular Navy channels to
see what they want to do but he made a
mistake but he shouldn't have done that
and your secretary probably shouldn't
have said quite what he said he didn't
have to resign but he felt it would be
better for the country so I you know I
think it's it will end it quickly a
couple on the economic front the two
hundred fifty billion dollars that was
added today will be added for the small
business loan program brings it to six
hundred billion in total do you think
that figure is enough when you see
hundreds of thousands of applications
don't forget they're for three thousand
dollars for seven thousand some for a
couple of million I guess one of the
banks said a couple of million so
therefore different very varying amounts
of money and there's a limit on the top
and then there's really no limit on the
bottom as to what it might be but it's
really popular it's hundreds of
thousands of applications they really
like it what I like is it keeps these
companies together these little
companies like we're gonna help the
airlines and the big companies we're
gonna help the little companies and the
bank's run nobody's equipped to do a
thing like that but the banks are
equipped so the banks are doing at big
banks small banks we have many banks
community banks and they're processing
the loans and they'll be able to watch
it and make sure it's done properly talk
today serves well about potentially
reopening the economy
in the upcoming weeks you mentioned the
other day about a potential economic
taskforce can you give us some sort of
update as to where think about that but
we want to open up but we want to get it
open soon that's why I think maybe we're
getting to the very top of the curve
I spoke with Governor Cuomo and he seems
to think that he's getting close and I
think a lot of people think that a lot
of places are getting close we want to
start heading that hitting the downside
and I think we're going to be do this is
going to be a very difficult week
however this week will be a very
difficult week because that's the most
difficult week when you're at that
position and we'll see what happens it's
gonna do a lot we wanna I really think
that with the stimulus we can be maybe
even beyond we're gonna do perhaps
infrastructure which you wouldn't have
gotten approved before and now people
are looking to do it and the beauty is
we're paying zero interest or very close
to zero interest and so guess is we're
paying actually zero have no interest
charge and the dollar is very strong and
people are investing in the dollar they
want you know the fact that we have the
strong currency we have the currency we
our currency is is everything and other
companies other countries want to be in
our currency so we're we're getting all
of the investment wanting to come into
the dollar the dollar is the strength
the dollar is the whole ballgame we have
a strong dollar other currencies are
going down way way down in some cases
you look at other countries I won't
mention them but other countries are
going down 22 percent 25 percent 28
percent and it's very hard for them that
makes it much more difficult with us our
currency is relatively now stronger than
it ever was or it was over the last few
years relative to other countries it's
always relative to other countries what
our currency is very strong so therefore
people want to invest if we do a bond
issue to do infrastructure everybody
wants a piece of that issue even at zero
interest yeah please
you see these memos that reportedly
Peter Navarro wrote back in January when
did you see them and how does that these
memos sort of square with what you've
often said that nobody could have
predicted this it sounds like he was
predicting I didn't see him but I heard
he wrote some memos talking about
pandemic I didn't see him I didn't look
for him either but that was about the
same time as I felt that we should do it
we know was about the same time that I
closed it down I asked him about it just
a little while ago because I read
something about a memo I said did you do
a memo I didn't look for I didn't see it
I didn't ask him to show it to me he
said yes I talked about the possibility
of a panda but nobody said it's going to
happen but you know there is a
possibility there always has been a
possibility but people wouldn't talk
about it but it was right about the time
that I closed it down and interestingly
the World Health Organization was not in
favor of us closing it down and if we
didn't close it down we would have lost
hundreds of thousands more lives you
were still downplaying the threat of
coronavirus in the u.s. you were saying
things like I think it's a problem
that's going to go away with the new
trail ready to go it will go you said
within a couple of days the cases will
be down to zero well the cases really
didn't build up for a while but you have
to understand I'm a cheerleader for this
country I don't want to create havoc and
shock and everything else but ultimately
when I was saying that I'm also closing
it down I obviously was concerned about
it because I closed down our country to
China which was heavily infected I then
closed it down to Europe that's a big
move closing it down from China and then
closing it down from Europe and then
ultimately closing it down to the UK so
and it was right about that time but I'm
not going to go out and start screaming
this could happen this could happen so
again as president I think a president
has to be a cheerleader for their
country but at the same time I'm
cheerleading I'm also closing down a
very highly infected place specifically
the
location as you know in China that had
the problems and we're closing it down
but we closed it down to all of China
then we closed it down to all of Europe
those were big moves and it was right
about that time today
sure you learned about the demo today
just about it maybe you feel like some
on your staff or themselves should've
told you it was a recommendation who's a
feeling that he had I think he told
certain people in the staff but it
didn't matter I didn't see it but I did
I closed it down I don't remember it
even being discussed we had a meeting
where there were a lot of people most
people felt they should not close it
down that we shouldn't close down to
China but I felt we had to do it and
that was it almost the exact same time
as the memo if you had read the memo at
the time how would that have changed the
steps you personally want to change
because I did I basically did what the
memo said and the memo was you know the
memo was pretty good memo from the
standpoint that he took I guess I didn't
see it yet us warning that the u.s.
could lose trillions of dollars in
millions of lives lives but you you'll
lose plenty of money but I couldn't have
done it any better because it was about
the same time and I closed it down to
China just like you so you maintain
confidence and
who is that man he wrote a memo and he
was right and I haven't seen the memo
I'll see it later on after this but it
didn't matter whether I saw it or not
because I I acted on my own I guess I
had the same instinct says Peter Peters
a smart guy he's a good guy and he's
done a wonderful job but he wrote a memo
and I guess he talked to various people
about it but ultimately I did what the
memo more or less what the memo said
just about the time the memo came out I
closed it down I took a lot of heat the
world you know health organization was
very much against they didn't like it
they actually put out statements about
it
in all fairness to Joe Biden he called
me xenophobic like I don't like China I
like China like the Chinese people are
phenomenal people so I was called
xenophobic I was called racist how could
I do a thing like this now since then
Joe said that he was wrong and he said
that I was right but I closed it down
and I was called names by some of the
morning show hosts who don't have a clue
what they're talking about they're not
smart people and I was called all sorts
of names when I closed it down to China
now they try and hide that you know the
tape of them saying terrible things but
that was a great decision if I didn't do
it if I didn't do that we would have had
hundreds of thousands more people dying
yeah please oh and I was wondering dr.
Kashi had discuss tomorrow and I think
that's that's good and he's worked with
him for a long time but they did give us
some pretty bad play calling so I think
given lots of countries in the world
accurate chronic virus testing that's
been central to your guys data model and
so I don't know I can only say that with
regard to us they're taking a lot of
heat because they didn't want the
borders closed they called it wrong they
called they really called I would say
every aspect of it wrong until the
bottom freeze we fund it take a look and
we go through step by step they said
there's no big deal there's no big
problem
there's no nothing and then ultimately
when I closed it down they actually said
that I made a mistake in closing it down
and it turned out to be right but at the
time they you know they did that so
we're just gonna take a look at it you
know we fund it and and they seem to be
you know I said recently a social media
said they seem to be very china centric
that's a nice way of saying it but they
seem to be very china centric and they
received it they're always on the side
of China and we fund it you know so I
want to look into it yes it's the time
to freeze funding to the WHL during a
pandemic look at it did we give it some
ended no I didn't I said we're gonna
look at it we're going to investigate it
we're gonna look at it but we will look
at ending funding yeah because you know
what they called it wrong and if you
look back over the years even they're
very much everything seems to be very
biased toward China that's not right to
follow-up we talked about African
Americans and having been
disproportionately affected by the
corona buy used to be unfortunately do
you plan on requiring the CDC of any
federal agencies or state agents public
public places doing tests and private
companies doing tests to collect that
data
well the race of the people being tested
and the the race of the people being
treated and how are we just seeing
tremendous wishing tremendous evidence
that African Americans are affected and
a far greater percentage number than
other citizens of our country because
we're dealing with our country now we're
looking at it from a worldwide
standpoint Tony Fauci is looking at it
very strongly but these numbers have
started to come out and then they're
very strong and they're pretty obvious I
think one of the things that we're gonna
be doing with our Medicare data is to do
that analysis we're gonna look back at
the last month or so and look at you
know related type illnesses going
forward we now have a code for
coronavirus so we can actually stratify
i buy demographic information so we can
look at race as a factor we can also
look at what the underlying health
issues are as well so we'll be providing
that data very shortly but we will be
doing that analysis this is something
that's come up over the list
I hadn't heard this and then over the
last few days this is coming up one more
and I don't mean by a little bit I mean
many times it's a real thing now we want
to find cures we want to find
therapeutics we want to find vaccines
because that will solve everybody's
problem but why is it that the
african-american community is so much
you know numerous times more than
everybody else and we want to find the
reason to it and dr. Fauci seemeth both
of them and others are working on this
and they're gonna have very good I would
say over the next in less than a week I
think you know a lot but what's
happening is we're trying to find out
why is it that it's three and four times
now maybe that's not going to be the
final number but why is it three or four
times more so for the black community as
opposed to other people it doesn't make
sense and I don't like it
and we're going to have statistics over
the next probably two to three days okay
thank you I'd like to ask the question
on behalf of myself and a colleague who
couldn't be here due to social
distancing thank you with Hearst
Newspapers I'm the prisoner today thank
you some banks are only providing
paycheck protection program loans to
clients with whom they have existing
banking relationships and you spoke to
banking CEOs today I wonder if you
you'll ask them these lenders to accept
applications from all small businesses
not just the businesses with whom they
have existed they'll be doing this but
we're also working with small community
banks so they will be doing that it's a
question I've already spoken about I
mean in many cases they have long term
relationships with thousands of
companies I was amazed to see how many
you know you saw the number of
applications it's hundreds of thousands
it's a lot of work but I did ask that
question and they are working on that
thank you and my my second question from
a colleague is congressman Gerry
Connolly a Democrat from Northern
Virginia told the local DC CBS station
that you personally requested the Kerr's
Act stimulus bill be stripped of 25
billion dollars for the postal service
Connolly claims that unless the USPS
gets that 25 billion the agency will be
run out of money by June he accuses you
of hastening the demise of the postal
service I'm the reason the Postal
Service Service has lost billions of
dollars every year for many many years
I'm the devices the new one I'm now the
demise of the Postal Service I'll tell
you who's the demise of the Postal
Service are these Internet companies
that give their stuff to the postal
service packages and I don't know why
they're not you know I don't run the
Postal Service you have a group of
people so-called independent people and
they run it but these packages are they
deliver they lose money every time they
deliver a package for Amazon or these
other Internet companies these other
companies that deliver they drop
everything in the post office they say
you deliver it and if they'd raise the
prices by actually a lot then you'd find
out that the post office could make
money or break even but they don't do
that and I'm trying to figure out why
these are independent boards that were
appointed by other
ministrations they're sort of long-term
they're there for a long time and I've
been talking to them all so you can look
it up take a look
they should raise they have to raise the
prices to these companies that walk in
and drop thousands of packages on the
floor of the post office and say deliver
it and they make money but the post
office gets killed okay so they ought to
do that and we're looking into it and
we've been pushing them now for over a
year and you know that because you've
seen the stories I'm pushing them it's
not fair for them to to these great
wonderful modern companies they walk
into our old post office with all these
routes that could never be built
you could never build them they go into
areas at you you could never do and they
say here deliver this and they lose a
lot of money per package and they have
to raise their prices but this postal
commission doesn't do it now we just got
a chance to point a couple of people
onto the Commission as I understand it
and that's good but they have to raise
their prices otherwise they're just
gonna lose a lot of money and tell your
Democrat friend that he ought to focus
on that because if he focused on that he
could truly save the post office post
office has been losing billions of
dollars a year for many many years and
have him take a look at that because
that's the way to solve the problem
thank you so much separate then you say
this we could be very painful very
difficult but few weeks ago we say this
was just like a flu what have you
learned I just say two weeks ago this is
me as a device to foreign leaders who
still are acceptable about this pandemic
and were against social distancing what
is your advice what you said I said it
was just like a flu so the worst
pandemic we ever had in this world was a
flu and it was called you know that it
was in 1917 1918 and anywhere from fifty
to a hundred million people died that
was a flu okay so you could say that I
said it was a flu or you could say the
flu is nothing to sneeze at what can you
offer as an advice affari leaders who
are skeptical skeptical about this for
me making war against social distancing
well I think there aren't too many of
them if you look throughout the world
and everyone just about everyone that
has practiced that is now closing up
well the UK was an example now they talk
about Sweden but Sweden is suffering
very gravely you know that right Sweden
did that the heard they call it the
heard Sweden suffering very very badly
it's a way of doing it but the minoo a
body has been watching everybody else
and so far almost every country has done
it the way we've done it we've chosen to
do it if we didn't do it that way we
would have lost hundreds of thousands of
more people okay
there's voting going on today in
Wisconsin there were points about
thousands of people waiting in how
long lines as they've had to wait around
personal health and their civic
responsibility what do you think that
the Supreme Court was right in students
or that that voting should go forward
the absentee extension she does take
place
look the Supreme Court and of course
they were right because what the
Democrats wanted and and you know what
this happened I supported a man named
Justice Kelly who's Daniel Kelly highly
respected justice and I supported him
just the other day social media I know
of him he's a just a you know fantastic
judge justice and I endorsed him and as
soon as they endorsed him they wanted to
move the election they didn't want to
move the election as soon as I endorsed
him the Wisconsin Democrats say oh let's
move the election to two months later
three they didn't mind having the
election until I endorsed him which is
very interesting now they talked about
Oh safety safety well it was 15 minutes
after I put out an endorsement that they
said we have to move the election they
didn't want to move the election before
that the other thing they want to do
which is crazy at the end of the
election they wanted to have one week
four proxies to come in or mail ballots
no mail ballots they cheat okay people
cheat mail ballots a very dangerous
thing for this country because they're
cheaters they go and collect them
they're fraudulent in many cases you got
a vote and they should have voter ID by
the way you want to really do it right
yeah voter ID but the Democrats and this
was turned over in the Supreme Court
yesterday I give great credit to the
court they actually didn't want to have
an election day they wanted to have
election day and then a week after
election day you choose you can't but
all these ballots come in these mailed
ballots come in the mail ballots are
corrupt in my opinion and they collect
them and they get people to go in and
sign them and then they've their
forgeries in many cases it's a horrible
thing and so what happened is the
Democrats in Wisconsin they had no
problem with the election being today
until I endorsed the Republican
candidate Justice Kelly Daniel Kelly and
as soon as I endorsed him they went
crazy they went crazy and you know
that's true
and now all of a sudden because go back
two weeks go back two days they didn't
want to move the election they were
having the election they will find cuz
they thought they were gonna win the
election then I endorsed him and all of
a sudden they think they're not now I
understand there are lines that go back
a long way I hope they're gonna vote for
justice Kelly with millions of pills of
hydroxychloroquine donated is there a
plan or system in side effects the side
effects are the least of it you have
people dying all over the place and
generally the side effects are really
with the z-pak having to do with the
heart the z-pak that's the antibiotic
not with the hydroxychloroquine so a
woman last night I watched her on one of
the shows good show Laura and she was
she thought she was dead she was a
representative from Michigan she was
just in horrible shape for 12 days 14
days she thought she was dead I think
she said that her doctor said she's you
know it's gonna be very tough she saw me
talking about this and she asked her
husband to go to the drugstore now this
is a Democrat representative a person
that you know perhaps wouldn't be voting
for me I think she'll be voting for me
now even if she's a Democrat even if
she's a Democrat representative and they
went to the sewer which I made available
because we have millions of doses we
have I think 29 million doses of this
drug and she has two husbands she said
please go out I'm not gonna make it
plead you have to hear her story please
go out get it he won at 10 o'clock in
the evening to the drugstore he got it
he gave it to her now you know I don't
say it works like this at all
four hours later she awoke and she said
I feel better and then shortly
thereafter she
great there's a woman that thought she
was gonna die it's I mean she's a
Democrat representative highly respected
woman African American woman I don't
know if you saw it as you asked the
question about African American she was
an African American woman a great woman
her her manner of speaking her the way
she told the story was beautiful I asked
my husband to go and get it he got it
she is now okay I mean she was
interviewed last night on television and
she thanked me she thanked me even in a
tweet she said I want to thank President
Trump he saved my life
look I don't say that happens with
everybody but that's a beautiful story
there are many of those stories and I
say try it
okay please you're gonna die and you're
gonna die I mean it's you're not gonna
die from this bill now there could be
some side effects but the side effects
is really more so from the c-pen doctors
have to recommend it I want doctors I'm
not saying I'm not a doctor I'm just
saying we hear great results and some
people say let's go to a laboratory
let's test it for a couple of years and
then I get we got people dying in this
country and all over the world right now
not in a couple of years they're dying
as we speak there are people dying and I
really think it's a great thing to try
just based on what I know again I'm not
a doctor and I say get a physicians
approval and they have physicians in
these hospitals great physicians brave
physicians they also say it's good for
the hospital workers to take them that
it's you know it's keeps it away it
keeps it out of your system I don't know
but there's a lot of good examples and
you know we have a 1,500 case study
going in New York and it's almost
complete so it'll be very interesting to
see what happens go ahead thank you sir
can you I appreciate that woman she was
great you have to see it to believe it
the way she spoke it was like a miracle
and this was not a fan of mine but she's
a fan of mine now and I'm very honored
by it go ahead
can you talk about your decision to
remove the land fine from the pandemic
response of accountability committee and
this sub that move and some of the
criticism you've leveled the deities how
does the American public have confidence
that they'll be over so we have a lot of
IGS in from the Obama era and as you
know it's the presidential decision and
I left them largely I mean to change
some but I left them but when we have
you know reports of bias and when we
have different things coming in I don't
know fine I don't think I ever met fine
I heard the name wasn't it if I heard
the name I don't know where he is maybe
was from Clinton okay you check that out
okay maybe he's from Clinton but we did
change him but we changed a number we
have about seven nominations in I
believe we put seven very very highly
qualified people for the IG position and
you know that's a decision that I could
have made three years ago and I could
have made two years ago and but we're
putting in not so much for him we're
putting in seven names I think it was
seven and they're going in now yeah
China century what exactly are you
talking about this because China is
underplayed how many I think you seem to
come down on the side of China don't
close your borders to China don't do
this they don't report what's really
going on they didn't see it and yet they
were there they didn't see what was
going on in Wuhan they didn't see it how
do you not see it they didn't see it
they didn't report it if they did see
they must have seen it but they didn't
report it please good turning back to
the voting in Wisconsin in those long
lines who will be responsible who should
be held responsible people get sick
after they voted look all I did was
endorse a candidate I don't know
anything about their lines I don't know
anything about their voting I love the
state I weigh as well one distinct which
is rare for a Republican to do but I won
the state of Wisconsin I'm gonna win it
again because we've been great to the
people of Wisconsin as you know with our
policies and they like me and I like
them but all I did was endorse
a candidate that's highly qualified very
respected person and all hell broke
loose as soon as I did that and then all
of a sudden they want to change before I
endorsed them they didn't want to change
this voting area there was no problem
with the Democrats voting until I
endorsed the candidate then they said
let's move it two months let's move it
three months later safety safety safety
right all of a sudden they want safety
well before I did the endorsement they
didn't talk about safety was fine four
months four months it was fine it was
always going to be and now I endorsed
and they want safety so you know how
does the election them holding this
election in Wisconsin line up with the
social distancing recommendations that
have come from your the people that you
have a Democrat in Wisconsin as governor
yes Kim that's his problem okay he
should be doing it again some governors
fail and I won't let them fail because
when they fail I'll help but that's run
by Democrats right now okay it's run by
Democrats you had a great great public
is it possible to socially distance when
you're voting you're going to have to
speak to the governor what you should do
is call the governor of Wisconsin and
ask him that question but also ask him
how come it was okay to do this until I
endorsed a candidate and as soon as I
endorsed him these lines are formed and
I hear Mike the lines are through the
roof so you know hopefully they're gonna
wrote they're gonna vote for the right
candidate yeppers yeah I was wondering
if you know where's the press give me
the press how can you ask a question
when you don't know the price I'll look
it up for you let me do someone else do
you were highly critical of
voting mailing your mail-in ballots for
me other than you anything goes we're
voting rights me up in Florida's
election in last month I could vote by
mail further because I'm allowed to
well that's called out-of-state you know
why I voted because I happen to be in
the white house and I won't be able to
go to Florida and look well there's a
big difference between somebody that's
out-of-state and does a ballot and
everything sealed certified and
everything else you see what you have to
do with the certifications and you get
thousands and thousands of people
sitting in somebody's living room
signing ballots all over the place
no I think that mail-in voting is a
terrible thing I think if you vote you
should go and even the concept of early
voting is not the greatest because a lot
of things happen but it's okay but you
should go and you should vote I think
you should go and you should vote you
look at what they do where they grab
thousands of mail-in ballots and they
dump it I'll tell you what and I don't
have to tell you can look at the
statistics there's a lot of dishonesty
going along with mail and voting million
dollars to buy their own medical
equipment but federal officials are kind
of swooping in and scooping up those
orders we're getting great prices on
equipment we're getting great prices and
equipment and we're helping the states
and the governors are very thankful mike
pence had a call yesterday with every
governor was on the call and every it
was like a love fest they're very happy
i don't know if they tell that to the
press some of them down some of them
will never say good to the press but
they know we've done a great job not a
good job a great job i think sometimes
it does and what we say is let us know
and we will immediately drop out of the
bidding let us know and we do that and
we drop out sometimes we tell them to
drop out because we've got a good price
you and then we'll deliver to them
no no not you in front please
some states have had trouble with
getting accurate death counts
particularly because of lack of testing
or no fishing discounts yes for the lack
of testing and no uniform systems would
you say death counts I think they're
pretty accurate on the death count
somebody dies I think the states have
been pretty accurate that's you know
what you're just saying no the death
counts I think they're very very
accurate I do say this I think if you
look at China and if you look at some of
these very large countries when you talk
about cases number of cases I would be
willing to bet they have more cases than
we do but they don't do the testing like
we do but you look at you know you look
at some of these certain countries and I
would be willing to bet a lot that they
had have more cases but we're more
accurate and our testing is done very
accurately and we've got a good process
did you have one yes please now I know
you're still busy trying to implement
roll three but as we move towards are
they still obstacles to that because
that would put money in American pockets
yeah I would love to see your payroll
good questions I would love to see a
payroll tax cut and I think on behalf of
the people it would be quick now it's a
longer term you know it's a longer time
because it's over a period of a year or
whatever you want to make it but I would
love to see a payroll tax cut there are
many people that would like to see it as
a permanent tax cut payroll tax cut well
the Democrats right now are stopping it
you know I don't know maybe they think
it's good politics to stop it
but you'd get a lot of people a lot of
money immediately you the payroll tax
cut would be a great thing for this
country I would like to have it
regardless of this but this would be a
fantastic time to have the payroll tax
cut the Democrats are stopping it but I
don't think they're you know I think
it's I think there's a certain
flexibility I think it's something that
we should do both the business and the
people but this would get money into the
hands of small business immediately
money in the hands of people the workers
and people immediately and it would be
over an extended period and it would be
simple to do it's so easy to do it's a
great tax cut and I'd love you to speak
to the Democrats and let's get it done
so I'm going to give this now to vice
president pence and they're going to go
over some very good statistics with
everybody and we'll have a couple of
answers on that because we're working
very hard on the african-american
community with respect to what's going
on because it's not it's not good I
don't like it
and we're gonna have some very good
statistics Tony I think over the next
couple of days so thank you all very
much thank you
[Music]
thank you all a few updates and then
I'll I'll introduce dr. deborah birx to
talk about what we're seeing around the
country what the data is telling us but
suffice it to say is the president said
several times it's a very tough week in
America and our hearts go out to all of
the families that have lost loved ones
to the coronavirus but I know I speak
for the entire White House coronavirus
Task Force when I say our hearts are
with the people of the Greater New York
City area today as we stand here today
in the midst of heartbreaking numbers of
losses in New York City I also want to
assure the American people that there
there's reason for hope as as dr. Burks
will enumerate in just a few moments
despite the increase in losses as as
Governor Cuomo articulated today
hospital admissions continued to decline
and in our report early this morning
from dr. Burks we continue to see
evidence of stabilization in some of the
areas around the country of the most
significant outbreak the New York metro
area including New Jersey Long Island in
Connecticut New Orleans metro area
Detroit Boston Chicago and and Denver as
dr. Burks will explain continue to give
evidence of stabilization which in a
very real sense is evidence that the
American people are putting into
practice the social distancing the
president's guidelines for our nation
and for that as as the president said
earlier today we thank the American
people
even in the midst of hardship and loss
at a time when we've seen more than
385,000 Americans test positive for the
coronavirus and more than 12,000 succumb
to this illness the evidence that dr.
Burks will describe to you will show
that the American people know our future
is in our hands and so as I begin allow
me just simply and to continue to urge
every American to put into practice the
guidance you're receiving from your
state and local authorities take it to
heart take it seriously
share it with your family and your
friends and and and and know that you're
making a difference America because you
truly are today for my part I spoke to
over 500 small business owners in a
conference call and there I heard about
their enthusiasm for the Paycheck
protection program and that call took
place before the President had the
Secretary of Treasury indicate our
interest in acquiring another two
hundred and fifty billion dollars for
that program as of this morning more
than 60 billion dollars in forgivable
loans that would cover two months of
paychecks at small businesses had
already been distributed and the number
is going to grow literally by the day
but we also had a very productive call
today with with some other American
heroes you know the we all have in our
hearts and in our minds our health care
workers and I'll speak for a moment
about the supplies and resources that
we're working to provide for all of them
but right below our health care workers
are all the people that are working in
critical infrastructure around the
country and and some of the most
important people are working in food
supply I mean from from the farmers and
the ranchers to our processors to our
distributors to our truckers to our
grocers Americans are keeping food on
the table for our fellow Americans and
let me begin by just saying what I said
to some of the most prominent CEOs of
meat and grain industry companies in the
country
companies like Tyson Foods and in Hormel
today not just these companies but to
all the hard-working people working in
food supply today thank you thank you
for what you're doing to keep those
grocery store shelves stocked thank you
for showing up for work every day and
working hard to keep that food supply
rolling in America you know it was more
than five weeks ago that the president
brought in all of the all the grocery
store leaders in the country and there
he received a commitment the no grocery
store in America would close and they
haven't but it's been these heroic
Americans from the farm to the fork that
have made it possible for Americans to
have one less worry and they are truly
inspiring heroes now that being said I
did hear from the industry today that
there have been reports of some plants
having reduced capacity because of
people having concerns about exposure to
the coronavirus in fact over the last
several days there's been some incidents
of worker absenteeism and some plants
have actually been forced to closed
temporarily and so on behalf of the
President on behalf of our entire team
and on behalf of a grateful nation let
me just say to all of you that are
working in the food industry at every
level across the country just understand
that you are vital you are giving a
great service to the people of the
United States of America and we need you
to continue as a part of what we call
our critical infrastructure to show up
and do your job and know that we're
going to continue to work tirelessly in
working with all of your companies to
make sure that that work place is safe
with that being said let me talk about
the other heroes that we always
mentioned at this podium today that dr.
Burks and dr. Fauci and very really
mentioned that's our health care workers
at the president's Direction we've been
working tirelessly literally around the
clock to identify resources around the
country and around the world to make
sure our health care workers have the
support that they need with some 51
major disaster declarations most
recently Minnesota being approved States
have stood up 27,000 national
but personnel-wise before the end
business today there will be more than
3000 Department of Defense and Health
and Human Service medical personnel on
the ground in the Greater New York City
area and those people will be redeployed
once that region of the country moves
through the corona virus epidemic in
that area and and we salute those
extraordinary patriotic Americans for
stepping forward to bring real relief to
our health care workers with regard to
equipment Oh Admiral pelagic reported to
the task force throughout the course of
the day today that we have continued to
distribute ventilators across the
country we're we're sending additional
ventilators from the strategic national
stockpile Maryland will receive 50
ventilators Delaware will receive 50
ventilators and that will leave more
than 8400 ventilator still in the
national stockpile one correction from
yesterday after our press briefing
yesterday
FEMA made a different decision with
regard to what state of California
generously made available and the
ventilators some 500 ventilators that we
again want to thank Governor Gavin
Newsom and the people of California for
donating to our nation's efforts 100 of
those are being deployed to New York 100
to New Jersey 100 to Illinois 50 to
Maryland 50 to Washington DC 50 to
Delaware and 50 to Nevada with regard to
the remainder of what we call personal
protective equipment again we've been
literally leaving no stone unturned
anywhere in the country or anywhere
around the world and there's Admiral
pull up Jack describe just a couple of
days ago we've established not just an
air bridge but a control tower system
modeled after military logistics out of
FEMA and Walla while FEMA is acquiring a
small portion of of what's being
acquired 90% of the supplies are being
are being routed directly into our
massive distribution system
and FEMA is using the data that dr.
Burks provides to target those resources
to the area's most in need I asked them
to break out a few details about
resources that just in the last five
days have been distributed and I hope
it's an encouragement to health care
workers all across these regions and
around the country about the efforts
that are being made to make sure they
have what they need you can see the New
York metro area including New Jersey
just in the last five days more than six
million n95 masks more than six million
surgical masks when Governor Cuomo and I
last spoke he told me there was a a real
challenge for medical gowns in the New
York City area and in New Jersey as well
and 2.8 million gowns were distributed
to that region as well going next to New
Orleans where again while we see some
encouragement challenges remain in that
community some eight hundred and thirty
seven thousand n95 mass for health care
workers 165 surgical masks other items
including almost 6 million gloves have
been distributed Detroit continues to be
a real focal point we're working closely
with Governor Gretchen Whitmer as well
as Mayor Mike Duggan and to meet the
needs of health care workers in Detroit
just in the last five days 1.6 million
n95 masks have been routed into the
health care system in Detroit nearly
700,000 surgical masks and in 24 million
gloves just as a portion of what's
displayed and in the Chicago metro area
which we continue to focus on each and
every day more than 1.7 million n95
masks have been routed into their health
care system 900,000 surgical masks 25
million gloves I share these details in
the hopes that health care workers
looking on will be encouraged at the
president's direction we are we are
making every effort to make sure you
have the resources you need to do your
job to do it safely and to go home safe
to your family even while you provide
that extraordinary and career
just care there healthcare workers are
providing literally around the clock in
the midst of the corona virus a
challenge the last slide is just the
cumulative numbers that we have
distributed and I'm happy in a few
moments to answer any questions about
that again the system that we have in
place is is one that is is essentially
infusing our major distribution networks
with millions of items and then FEMA is
directing on a day-by-day and oftentimes
hour-by-hour basis where those resources
are most needed and we'll continue to do
that as the coronavirus makes its way
through these communities and through
communities that are very much on our
watch list today and let me just lastly
say that again I want to thank the
American people for stepping up and
doing your part we continue to be
overwhelmed with one story after another
where people are doing social distancing
where people are looking after one
another where they're checking in with a
phone call to an elderly friend a family
member to make sure they're okay
and we are on the front end of 30 days
to slow the spread and I will tell you
as a non-scientist up here that I see
glimmers of hope in the early numbers
that we're seeing come out of the
Greater New York City area New Jersey
even New Orleans and Detroit and Chicago
there does appear to be as dr. Burks
will explain in more detail it does
appear to be evidence of leveling
evidence of progress but this is exactly
the time for all of us to redouble our
efforts to do everything each and every
one of us can not just to protect our
own health and that of our family and
our loved ones but to do our part to
ensure that we lessen the impact of the
corona virus on America as a whole but
but even more importantly that we that
we lessen the impact on lives by
ensuring that we do our part to make
sure that no one that is volatile
is unnecessarily exposed to this virus
with that let me yield to dr. Burks and
then Seema Varma and dr. pouchy and
we'll take all your questions Thank You
mr. vice president so hopefully you can
see from this numbers that we've taken a
data detailed approach really bringing
the power of granular data to the supply
chain and moving supplies based on
really what you would call burden of
disease and need if I could just take
start out by not just going to the
numbers at the beginning but really
talking to the community of health
advocates to the community that works on
the social determinants of disease and
the communities of the historic black
colleges and universities we really need
to improve messaging and I'm asking them
to help us increase the messaging around
this we don't want to give the
impression that the african-american
community is more susceptible to the
virus we don't have any data that
suggests that where our data suggests is
they are more susceptible to more
difficult and severe disease and poorer
outcomes and we really need to make sure
that every household is aware of what
it's going to take to protect the
individuals in that household that have
pre-existing conditions we could call on
the indigenous nations the rila tribal
leaders to also be working very closely
to protect the elders of their
communities we know this is more
difficult in multi-generational holds
and it's really going to call for a
really unbelievable attention to details
of hand-washing and protecting others
from each other particularly if you
don't feel well this is really a call to
action to the communities to make sure
that we get messages appropriately out
there so that everyone understands what
it's going to take for us all to protect
one another and we know it can be done
because we can see these changes I
wanted to go through the numbers at a
high level so you understand why
particularly these supplies went to
these areas to begin with we talked
about attack rates or the cases poor per
population so in the New York as a state
they have seven cases
thousand this is the highest in the
country in New York City itself it's
closer to almost twice that in New York
City New Jersey is for four thousand
Louisiana three per thousand
Massachusetts to four thousand
Connecticut two per thousand Michigan
one point five four thousand the
District of Columbia in the Baltimore
area now one point five per thousand and
we're watching them very closely
Pennsylvania one per thousand but we're
concerned about Philadelphia what is
allowing us to move supplies based on
burden of disease in need is the
extraordinary West Coast that has had
very low numbers from Washington that
was less than one per thousand
California that is less than 0.5 per
thousand and Oregon that's even less
than that and it's those states where
there's large populations because of the
enormous work that they're doing to
prevent expansion and spread of the
virus it's allowing resources to go to
these these states and these communities
in these counties that need more support
and so this kind of data analysis is
allowing us to make very intelligent
decisions about need but also really
understanding what's happening across
the country in the development of the
curves as you have heard about and so we
do see and I know you heard me caution
that over the weekend sometimes there's
decreased case reporting and so there
were increases in a series of
communities on Monday we're seeing that
stabilize again and when you look over
three days you're starting to see that
we may be actually in a series of
communities outside of New York and New
Jersey and Connecticut creating a much
flatter graph the most a much flatter
curve so you saw New York and they
increase and then you saw we're hoping
as as Governor Cuomo and May and the
mayor has described that they're getting
to a steady state where the next outcome
is going down but we see across the
country in Detroit in Chicago some real
not this extreme going to seven cases
per thousand but
staying in the more - cases per thousand
and a different curve parameter than and
it really shows the amazing amazing
activity of every American in those
cities to really ensure that their
social distancing and really importantly
to ensure there is less socialization
between households and really ensuring
that the household really remains
independent and protected and not really
at this moment
going out into the community or
socializing anywhere but a virtual way
on computers by zoom by FaceTime and I
think we can really see that in the data
and its really given us great heart I
want to finish by really talking to my
laboratory directors because you're
extraordinary and you've done an amazing
amount of testing those nearly two
million tests that we're getting to
those were all done in the last two to
three weeks but we do have s excess
capacity so of all the lab directors
could look in their laboratories if they
have an an avid M 2,000 if they could
get that up and running we could double
the number of tests that we're doing per
day that is a high throughput the
machines are throughout the United
States there's hundreds of them right
now about 80% of them are idle we're
going to have a call with the laboratory
directors of these laboratories to
really ensure this is an automated
robotic situation that they can run
there's over a million tests sitting
test kits sitting ready to be run we
have five platforms of tests this is one
of our really high-volume platforms like
Roche and we're really calling on them
to really increase that capacity so that
we can do not only increase diagnostic
testing which I think we're doing quite
well right now but also increasing the
ability to do more health care workers
first responders community testing and
surveillance and so and then finally you
will see and you've heard about it
happening in the UK and other places
there's a series of antibody tests out
there
that have not been validated we're
working right now very closely with a
series of companies that know how to
make these tests that have made these
tests for us for decades for HIV for a
rapid test they're working on that
technology to bring that quality of test
which is in the 90 plus percent
sensitivity and specificity to the
American people for antibody tests but
before until we get those if you see
them on the internet do not buy them
until we can give you a test that's
reliable for all Americans and we are
working very hard to have that happen
and bring that to the American public
some of the tests that may be available
on the Internet may have very low
sensitivity and specificity and give you
a Fuss reassurance that you either give
you a false positive or a false negative
implying that you may be protected so
please wait until we have those tests
available and validated that people are
working around the clock to make those
available to the American people we all
understand how important that is because
you've heard us talk about asymptomatic
cases and we really want to know how
broad that is and how common that is and
so in places like New York City where I
described that they had a seven four
thousand sometimes two three and four
times any other place in the United
States being able to know what the
number of people who never had symptoms
but do have a positive test would be
really critical at this point
particularly as we plan for any
reoccurrence in the fall or in future
seasons thank you
and we as Sima Verma reads the Center
for Medicaid Medicare services we'll
discuss what we've done to support
hospitals as we support healthcare
workers we're going to make sure the
institutions that are providing the
environment for care are well financed
and she's got a couple of funding
streams and help us on the way let me
just start with echoing the president
and the vice president's comments about
our condolences to all the people out
there that have lost somebody to the
coronavirus and also a you know sincere
appreciation and thanks to all our
health care workers that are on the
front lines but we know that it's the
impact on the health care system isn't
just those front care frontline workers
health care organizations across the
nation are having increased expenses
they're having to spend more on supplies
you're seeing all of the supplies that
are being sent to them and that's having
a direct impact on their on their bottom
line many of them are also having
increased expenses because they're
taking advantage of some of the
flexibilities that we've given them
hospitals without walls they're putting
you may see tents out in their parking
lots where they're doing testing or
screening so they have a lot of
increased expenses as well other health
care organizations are not performing
essential surgeries or other services a
lot of them are moving to telehealth and
that represents lost revenue for these
health care organizations across the
country and so the president has asked
us to address this issue about 10 days
ago we put out something called
accelerated payments that we do in the
Medicare program and it allows us to
advance payments to providers based on
their historical Medicare revenues that
they receive so it just in 10 days we've
been able to provide payments to
providers we had about 25,000 requests
we've processed about 70% of these it's
happened in about five days and the
total on that is about 34 billion
dollars that we've managed to put into
the healthcare system but those are
essentially loans president has asked us
to go further with this and to start the
implementation of the cares Act that
provides a hundred billion dollars
to the healthcare system you've heard
secretary azar talk about the focus on
some of those dollars going towards the
uninsured but the president want us to
accelerate getting those dollars out and
so this week we will be putting out
another 30 billion dollars which are
grants this is going to be based on
Medicare revenue there are no strings
attached so the health care providers
that are receiving these dollars can
essentially spend that in any way that
they see fit also this is going to be
done a very easy simplified way for many
of our health care providers we actually
do direct deposit with them and so those
dollars will just go right into their
bank accounts for other providers all
it's going to require is some very
simple registration and we'll be able to
give them that money as well so we're
expecting that to happen this week the
other thing to note is that this is not
a first-come first-served basis because
we're basing this on their Medicare
revenue they will get these dollars so
even if it takes a few days there
shouldn't be any panic in the system as
well um the other thing to recognize
here is that our priority was on getting
these dollars out as quickly as possible
we heard that from the many health care
providers across the country that
weighed in on this they said the most
important thing was to get these dollars
out as quickly as possible but we
recognize that in terms of getting these
dollars out because it's based on
Medicare revenues there are providers
out there pediatricians children's
hospitals OBGYNs even our nursing homes
that a lot of their revenue comes from
other sources Medicaid or other payer
sources and so those organizations will
be addressed in the second tranche of
funding and we'll have a priority for
these organizations and these types of
health care providers also just want to
say so together between the loans that
we've put out there with our accelerated
payments and the 30 billion that's about
64 billion for the healthcare system
this week alone and so I think again
this is part of our effort to support
the healthcare system and and also just
want to again say thank you to all our
healthcare providers out on the front
lines to all Americans the best thing
that we can do to support our health
care providers is to adhere to those
guidelines around 30 days to slow the
spread that is a
thing that we can do to support our
healthcare workers thank you I just want
to make a brief comment to get back to
the discussion about the health
disparities in the african-american
community because it really is very
important and the reason I want to bring
it up because I couldn't help sitting
there reflecting about sometimes when
you're in the middle of a crises like we
are now with the corona virus it really
does have ultimately shine a very bright
light on some of the real weaknesses and
foibles in our society and as some of
you know I the greater proportion of my
professional career has been defined by
hiv/aids and if you go back then during
that period of time when there was
extraordinary stigma particularly
against the gay community and it was
only when the world realized how the gay
community responded to this outbreak
with incredible courage and dignity and
strength and activism that I think that
really changed some of the stigma
against the gay community very much so I
see a similarity here because health
disparities have always existed for the
african-american community but here
again with the crisis how it's shining a
bright light on how it's unacceptable
that is because yet again when you have
a situation like the corona virus they
are suffering disproportionately as dr.
Berg said correctly it's not that
they're getting infected more often is
that when they do get infected their
underlying medical conditions the
diabetes the hypertension the obesity
the asthma those are the kind of things
that wind them up in the ICU and
ultimately give them a higher death rate
so when all this is over and as we said
it will end we will get over coronavirus
but there will still be health
disparities which we really do need to
address in the african-american
community Thanks
questions for our panel
mr. vice president and then a question
for dr. Burks as well on the ventilator
issue with 8400 of them and a stockpile
in tendons of thousands more coming
why are states like California in
Washington needing Descent ventilators
to other states that is that smart if
they might need them later on well I'm
gonna let dr. Burke speak about what's
happening in California in Washington
because it is a real credit to the
people of both states and the leadership
of both states to see the progress that
we've made we continue to witness that
the numbers where the outbreak began we
all remember when this first emerged in
the Seattle area the numbers continued
to be steady and low and what we've seen
the Governor of California do what we
saw the governor of Washington state do
and the governor of Oregon where the
coronavirus hasn't arrived to a large
extent in Oregon I think is in keeping
with the highest traditions of the
American spirit and there they are
understanding what I think I think
Americans are understanding more and
more that while we tend to think of this
as one large curve in our minds for when
it began in our country and we long for
the day that it will end and we want to
hasten that day by by putting into
practice all these mitigation efforts
that the reality is what these experts
have explained to this layperson is that
what what we're actually going to
witness is a number of small curves that
will cumulatively mean that curve and
for for Oregon for Washington State for
California to recognize where the need
is and then to partner with us and FEMA
to make sure the resources are there at
the time and the need of the point of
the need I think is really inspiring but
dr. Burks do you want to speak to them
yeah I want to be clear no we didn't ask
for their ventilators they looked at
their epidemia genealogic curves these
are these states have amazing health
commissioner's and I think when this is
over we'll really be all of the models
were based on something we have never
attempted to do anywhere in the
we have never attempted to do this kind
of mitigation
it was always theoretic to many
individuals and now we see across the
globe people mitigating against this
virus realizing that their own behaviors
can change the course and future of this
virus in their communities which is
really astounding the power that gives
us to actually understand that we can
compete against this virus and do well
and so I think they're governors and
their health commissioners looked at
their curves looked at their hospitals
looked at their ICU and looked at their
needs and then decided that they didn't
need those at this time and wanted to
make it available for other states that
were in more that two per thousand three
per thousand for four thousand and seven
per thousand and I think we'll learn a
lot from other states and other
communities to really understand how to
do this better next time and I think
this is what will it will teach us
because we've never we've never
attempted anything like this at least in
my lifetime where we've had you know
these 30 days to stop the spread I mean
we've not ever put out information like
that so I think that I think you heard
the CDC director talk earlier today
about in the models how different
individuals thought communities would
mitigate and the rate at which they
would mitigate mitigate and I think you
can see that across the world we're
learning that when you give communities
the information that they need to
understand what's going on and you're
transparent that communities can be part
of the solution in a transparent and
amazing way and I think this kind of
education and dialogue is always
critical when you want communities I
think when I first started here five
weeks ago I said that we will win based
on what the communities are able to do
as a community of Americans and I think
we're all really deeply impressed about
what they were able to do so it's the
governor's who decided the testing
backlog is an adequate follow-up
question on that how close are we to
getting into that 24
window you talked about being very
important and then what is the status of
the self swap test so we're tracking all
of that very closely I and I'm you know
I use my time here to appeal to people
specifically the health educators the
health advocates because I know the
power with them but to my lab directors
I really need the abbot em 2000 online
because that means we can do an extra
hundred thousand tests a day and there's
enormous power in that the self ability
to self test the ability last time I had
my test here I self tested on so it can
be done it's straightforward and it
works very well with that rapid
five-minute test but what we now have to
create and I know that's always
difficult because everybody wants one of
something we now have to create a mosaic
that brings together where we know every
single machine is in the United States
where our gaps are and then align
resources with need and gaps in the
testing and ensure that we have the
right laboratory test for the right
community so you can see there would be
communities particularly the Indian
Health Service of rural communities
where that a bat ID now kit could be
incredibly helpful because otherwise
they're shipping it all the way to
capital maybe three states away and
that's gonna add two or three days to
the wait time which we're trying to get
away from it varies state by state and
we'll be talking with all of the states
about really changing how we do testing
in the community to really ensure that
we're testing optimally because right
now we have still focused very much on
Hospital diagnosis because we know it
will make a difference in treatment so
these major laboratories are still
putting drive-through tests at the back
to all the hospital tests and so that's
where the backlog is in the
drive-through test so I know if you're
an outpatient not an inpatient but if
you're an outpatient
that is where the delays right now are
but that's state by state and so some
states have 24 hour 48 hours for both
their out patience and impatience others
have short for inpatient and longer and
outpatient and then we're trying to
reconcile those two pieces and the team
is actually meeting tonight to review
that but one of the data points that we
review is literally on a state-by-state
basis what the turnaround time is for
testing and we continue to work that in
these abbott laboratory devices are
there's 18,000 of them across the
country when you go to your doctor
office and get get a strep test
it's that device all all Abbott
Laboratories is done with strong and
Swift efforts of the FDA is created
tests to put in that for the coronavirus
and it's a 15 minute test and so we I
want to renew our our call to all the
healthcare providers around the country
is find your Abbott device and we'll
work our hearts out to get a test to you
come into that mr. president thank you
one for you and then one for either of
the doctors your life for you sir back
to this idea of reopening up the economy
since it's not like there's a switch
that you can just turn it back on how
does the administration envision this
happening is it guidance from the White
House and you hope the governor's follow
it are you gonna put it in the
governor's hands or the mayor's hands
how do you envision all of that working
together well the one thing I can assure
you is that the president's decision in
that regard is going to be informed by
what the data shows and and about
decisions about when we can responsibly
reopen America and put America back to
work I can tell you the CDC will have
new guidance tomorrow that the CDC will
be publishing for people who were in
proximity to an individual that tested
positive for coronavirus but have no
symptoms and CDC will be publishing new
guidance about how those individuals and
the circumstances under which they might
be able to return back to work using
some facial protection and monitoring
their temperature but we'll detail that
for you but what we're going to be doing
over the weeks
and is while we focus every day at the
point of the need as the president said
many times our first mission is to save
lives and that means to slow the spread
bend the curve to continue to engage the
American people which they are admirably
doing to continue to put all the social
distancing into practice but there is a
dual track that the president has
already initiated some of the best minds
here at the White House are beginning to
think about what recommendations will
look like that we that we give to
businesses that we give to States but
it'll all I promise you be informed on
putting the health and well-being of the
American people first for dr. Burks or
for dr. grouchy three if you want to
take that or secondly as a lot of
parents are sitting home with their kids
and they've been home with their kids
for weeks now and they're wondering
maybe resigned to the fact that maybe
their kids aren't going back to school
this year but I'm looking ahead what do
you think summer camp holds and what do
you think the start of next school year
holds down the line all the time do you
think school next year starts off fact
can I say a word on behalf of teachers
since I'm married to one my wife is all
day yesterday at the elementary school
she teaches have loading up about 500
bins of art supplies for kids and she's
just one of millions of teachers across
this country who find themselves having
to distance teach kids and I'm proud of
Karen but relatedly I'm proud of every
teacher in this country Secretary of
Education was here not long ago talking
about our efforts to expand distance
learning resources even in K through 12
to all the teachers who are out there we
just want to say thank you thank you for
what you're doing for continuing
learning even in this challenging time
and to all of the kids just because
you're home doesn't mean you don't have
to do your school work what I will tell
you is all yield to the health experts
but it'll be part of what
in terms of of guidance going forward
whether it whether it be summer school
or whether it be returning to school
next fall but the most important thing
we can do is put this epidemic behind us
as quickly as possible my daughter is
the schoolteacher so she asked me to see
the same question you know it is
unpredictable but you can get a feel for
if we start talking about the things
where the curve goes down and we really
have minimal how we respond and what
kind of a rebound we see or don't see I
think it's gonna have a lot of influence
probably more immediately on things like
summer camps than it does in the fall I
fully expect though I'm humble enough to
know that I can't accurately predict
that by the time we get to the fall that
we will have this under control enough
that it certainly will not be the way it
is now where people are shutting schools
my optimistic side tells me that we'll
be able to renew to a certain extent but
it's going to be different remember now
because this is not going to disappear
so we're gonna have to have in place the
capability of doing the things that we
talk about all the time on this stage to
identify to isolate to contact trace
number one number two by that time we'll
have a better feel with the antibody
test about what the actual penetrance of
this infection was in society how many
people have actually been infected who's
protected if you have anybody it's very
likely that you're protected who's
vulnerable do you treat vulnerables
different than you treat the people who
are protected all of these things are
gonna go into the decision of just how
much back to the original way we would
like it to be in the fall bottom line is
no absolute prediction but I think we're
going to be in good shape
twenty-four-hour dr. Caggiano - burps -
can you talk about your concerns about
deaths being misreported by coronavirus
because of either by testing for
standards for how they're characterized
so I think in this country we've taken a
very liberal approach to mortality and I
think the reporting here has been pretty
straightforward over the last five to
six weeks prior to that when there
wasn't testing in January and February
that's a very different situation and
unknown there are other countries that
if you had a pre-existing condition and
let's say the virus called you to go to
the ICU and then have a heart or kidney
problem some countries are recording
that as a heart issue or a kidney issue
and not a kovin 19 death right now we're
still recording it and we all I mean the
great thing about having forms that come
in and a form that has the ability to
market as Cova 19 infection the intent
is right now that those if someone dies
with covin 19 we are counting that as a
köppen 19 death are you can you be sure
when you hear from coroner's that that's
not necessarily the case or are you sure
how can you be confident about that and
is there any concern that its views
the data that you're trying to collect
in terms of projections well I think
that would apply more to rural areas
that may not have the same level of
testing but I am pretty confident in New
York City and New Jersey and places that
have these large outbreaks and kovat
only hospitals I can tell you they are
testing New York and New Jersey together
have a by proportion are testing
extraordinary well as Washington State
and Louisiana so I don't see that
there's been a barrier in testing to
diagnosis there's so much focus now on
coronavirus that particularly if you
take New York which we all know is is is
having a disproportionately higher
proportion of the burden of the entire
country is right now in New York now I
can't imagine if someone comes in with
coronavirus goes to an ICU and they have
an underlying heart condition and they
die they're gonna say cause of death
heart attack III cannot see that that
happening so I don't think it's gonna be
a problem a question for dr. pouchy on
the virus hitting black communities the
hardest I mean these numbers are
staggering Louisiana and other states
are reporting 40 to 70% of deaths or
african-americans do you expect that
pattern to continue nationwide some
states have not even reported their data
yet you know I I can't be confident to
predict patterns but the underlying
reason why that is happening doesn't
change from state to state worse no I
expect that when African Americans get
infected given the disproportionate
disparity of the underlying conditions
that lead to complications like the ones
I mentioned I expect that we will still
see the pattern that when you look at
the proportion of people who get into
serious trouble and die again it's going
to be disproportionate towards the
African Americans I do expect that and
is the federal government now leading
the charge and collecting this
information from the states and when
will
being public yes the answer is yes it
will be public as soon as you get enough
data to be able to make a meaningful
statement so can we expect this week or
a couple of days task force says assign
that to several members of the team
we're assembling that data now it's a it
is a it is a great concern for us and
but it's it's probably a good reminder
that we have to be especially careful
around people with serious underlying
health conditions because we've said it
many times from this podium over many
weeks that the risk of serious illness
from the corona virus remains low for
the average American but for anyone from
any community that has a serious
underlying health condition particularly
senior citizens with serious underlying
health conditions the risk of of tragedy
is very real and so we're gonna be very
diligent about studying this and
providing information and guidance in
accordance with our best scientists but
I do want to say to each and every
American the president's coronavirus
Guidelines for America about wash your
hands if you're if you're sick stay home
if you can work from home if you're not
in critical infrastructure like our
incredible health care workers or all
those heroic people working to keep food
on the shelves at our grocery stores and
keep medicine at the pharmacies we we
ask you to we ask you to work from home
if you can avoid unnecessary travel
avoid gatherings have more than ten
people use a drive-thru at a restaurant
don't go in the restaurant not just to
protect your health but to protect those
of every community of every background
in this country who may have underlying
conditions that make them susceptible to
tragic outcomes that's how we can all do
our part to slow the spread and to
protect our most vulnerable and the
American people are doing it and as we
continue to do that we will
Aysen the day that we put the corona
virus in the past and we reopen America
and put America back to work
thank you all we'll see you tomorrow